Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
I want to thank George who sent me this problem. The problem was given to George by his seventh grade math teacher, Ms. V.
Consider the following table.
All numbers in the first column have been increased by the same percentage P to give the results in the second column.
The resulting numbers are coded. Each digit is replaced by a letter.
A given letter stands for the same digit every time it appears in that column.
What is the value of P, the percentage increase?
Now I have received an email from a blind person who requested that when possible I read out the numbers that are on the screen.
So let me read out this table. It consists of eight rows with two columns.
The first column consists of a two-digit number and the second column consists of two letters, so let me read it out row by row
20 G C
15 I J
45 A C
35 C G
70 J C
80 H F
25 E B
and 60 D G
So can you figure out this seemingly impossible seventh-grade math problem?
Give it a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for a solution
So there may be many ways to solve this problem; here's how I figured it out and you can share your method in the comments.
Since the second column has distinct whole numbers,
we can limit the search to positive fractional increases.
So let's search for a common factor of the numbers in the first column.
I consider the numbers thirty-five and twenty.
Thirty-five is equal to five times seven and twenty is equal to five times four so
We can consider the common factor of five.
This gives the possibilities of fractional increases of 1/5, 2/5, 3/5, 4/5, and 5/5.
These correspond to percentage increases of 20%, 40%, 60%, 80%, and 100%
Which one is it?
Notice that 80 increased by 25% is equal to 100 which is a three-digit number
But the resulting number for 80 has only two digits
Therefore the percentage increase
has to be less than 25%.
This means the percentage increase is equal to 20% and you can check that that works.
For example, 20 increased by 20% is equal to 24, and 35 increased by 20% is equal to 42, and
And these are the same digits in the answer just reversed.
24, 42 - and G C and C G
And you could check it works. There are no other contradictions in the table so the correct answer is 20%.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video. Please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on math. You can catch me on my blog "mindyourdecisions".
If you like this video you can check out my books which are listed in the video description,
and you can support me on Patreon. If you have a math topic, you can email me presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com
And you can catch me on social media either @mindyourdecisions or @preshtalwalkar.